we should be live are we live yeah
thanks for waiting guys I was recording
La how y'all
doing
[Music]
yeah yeah no background music in the
beginning uh
cringe out vloging out
um
I'm just going to get a g Fuel and then
we'll get into this
[__] all right get hyped grab your
favorite beverage as
[Music]
well the chat froze what's going
on you guys alive oh you are there you
are hey guys
nice
[Music]
all right so just one minute and I'll we
get
[Music]
started
yeah what Su
[__] bit
tall
[__] oh no frame has to look good it was
all off
the last
episode can you guys see
me yeah
sweet boom
chat is going wild we got a big stream
ahead of us with a lot of Last of Us
damn thanks for the new members
guys you hyped as hell boy oh really
well so am I got my tower G
fuel well I was late because I was
recording a video video I think that's a
fair
excuse don't you huh how are you guys
it's Saturday
today oh that doesn't sound
right
okay streaming in the middle of the
night so for those of you who haven't
watched part one and two go and watch
them but if you don't have time
uh should I spoil what happened
I just want to summarize the story
really quick so Joel was
out ell was out but they were in
different places Joel saved
this uh audio is
delayed it's supposed to be
delay
by
bye uh what's delayed about it
there's no delay for [__] sake can you
guys [__] off
then yeah like he interrupting
everything
uh okay Joel
died while saving the [__] girl
that's what annoys me so much he saved
her life but she's still so revengeful
that she wants to kill him doesn't even
hesitate there has to be a reason for it
that we don't know about yet so I don't
want to be too like oh the game sucks
even though it does suck yeah it does
[__] suck I was thinking about it I'm
like did they not understand what made
the first game good at all or are they
just being spiteful are they creatively
lacking what what is the reason I just
can't figure it out and I I guess the
only way to find out is to keep playing
some people say the game gets a lot
better I also seen people say the
complete opposite that it just gets
worse and that made me really want to
keep playing so that uh uh we find out
what the [__] is going to happen cuz it
seems like such a mess such a
wide
uh range of emotions which makes it
interesting so uh we're now with the
Dena our love interest we always had a
backpacked so we could bail of and we're
looking for gas never and holy [__] I
already forgot how beautiful the game is
it
sucked we just had a little side quest
now where we did absolutely nothing that
was really great uh let's check the map
cuz we need to go somewhere else now so
there's no
gas possibly in the restaurant can you
guys tell where that's looking I guess
we need to turn
around go right and
then uh I didn't want to flip it for
[__]
sake I wish I wish another game looked
this good
rip Joel F's in the
chat am I going in the right direction
now yeah we just go straight from here
all right let's try
that look at
this Seattle that's in have a place we
north of California right am I wrong
I've been in Seattle should we check for
supplies so we can choose to check for
what you talking about oh they got dogs
sure
so yeah uh when I first got to Jackson I
was so overwhelmed by all the people
okay I I don't care I was overwhelmed by
all the food I remember my first week
just gorging myself people didn't say
that it's worth looking around so I'm
going to do that I saw that you didn't
that wanted posters I did I remember way
in here who is this string bean girl
stealing all the jerky can we climb this
didn't steal that much
jerky I missing something
obvious you mean the front door
Felix big
brain man imagine this place when
everything was intact you could just
Goof Off play some instruments ell you
don't play an
instrument you don't know how to play
anything I mean I could definitely
figure what the [__] did I do stop
trolling me I haven't died a single time
yet can't wait for your reaction to
Abby's
story
yeah [__] I don't want to play as her
anymore all right who we got D wart
that's wart This Tall laconic presence
seems unassuming enough bullied and
misunderstood early in his life due to
in his inability to speak about the
level of a Mumble he was forever changed
when an ancient Cosmic being bestowed
upon Him Z word a mystical phrase that
when spoke is that a [__] JoJo
reference is that a JoJo
reference all right I'm not going to
waste my time reading all of
these check this
out think there's enemies in any of
these that sounded nice enemies in any
of
these oh wow that was she playing The
Bongo that was an interesting beat
excuse me I am was that the PornHub
intro admit it I'll play I love you
whatever I'll we're starting a band I'm
just kidding how about you be my groupy
your what well okay fans apparently had
these hardcore fans that would just
follow them around are they going to
criticize that what I'm already
doing uh I guess so mhm cuz that's
definitely a thing of the
past uh is there something in there yeah
it is let's find something to break it
with oh I already have it
okay smash time Bing Bong oh you serious
what the [__] they got a bunch of
Records
here really they have records and
Records close enough did I not hit it
right I swear there something we only
listen to it like 100 times together I
was only listening to it cuz I thought
you were
cute torture
Abby okay there's an option I mean seems
fair I can punch
it
oh my
God are you
serious all right [__]
hey did not expect that to work not
going to
lie all right what's the the guitar case
hand a guitar
what that's not a
tune hey little
girl that [__] killed
Jo but she doesn't know how to
[Music]
play
what you can play as Joel
[Music]
what Abby's going to die AB AB is going
to die I hate that [__] I hate that
[__] ab's going to die ab's going to
die [__] that [__] [__] that [__] I
going to
die
[Music]
I'm
I thought I thought the thing was that
beautiful it's Debbie not Abby my bad my
bad
[Music]
dabby lose
you I think
I what was
that
nothing nothing you wouldn't understand
well nothing sure sounds
nice remember that night by the
bonfire
yeah all right I'm playing
[Music]
more
play a
[Music]
different don't
know to say I'll say
any
day that [__] BL take on
me I'll be coming for your love
okay J
[Music]
Me Take On Me
Take
me sing a
[Music]
chat
oh my God it we don't need to whole
[Music]
songs are serious
beow
[Music]
me
thanks for the copy strike Last of Us
appreciate
[Music]
it I would regret I'm not doing a single
more side
[Music]
quest
Ellie Maris Su
confirmed she said she's never taken
lessons then
he she plays better than
Joel you should have kissed me
then oh my God I wanted to it's so
great you've already kissed what's the
point all right we get it yeah
please
I'm never touching a guitar again in
this game [__]
that that was it we came for some screws
and some
Feller o $4.99 that's a great
price
you should have kissed me back then yes
but I didn't want to lose you as a
friend I don't think there's anything
else in
here
really can I craft anything
Noe all right you're sman I'd rather
kiss you not going to
lie Ellie I think Shimmer's getting sick
what I don't mind that scene this is a I
didn't expect the whole song to be
played boy and two songs a good
one all right we can't go
here checking the
map I was supposed to make a left here
we got disoriented all right we came
here yeah and there were the dogs
here oh there was a time Jump so he
taught her to play in between oh I see
that clears up that thanks
guys damn I love looking at the
buildings hey I think found the
courthouse how can you tell see that
sign up there on the building that says
Courthouse I legit don't see it oh well
nice work detective M thanks place on
the
map
can you're going to go
upstairs does horses know how to go
upstairs something I never thought
about Jo is floor again don't say that
more like Joel's brain is
for
Lo or
not eh worth a try let's keep looking
let's check on the
side look o I hear zombies right hear
that I hear it infected it's coming from
the courthouse oh hell yeah this going
to suck isn't it at least we're ready
for
him Climb
Time jol dirt gang Jesus
more
cocaine revolver ammo
nice you can equip one gun per holster
additional gun stored in your
backpack so quick draw swap
weapon okay that's kind of
cool
Golf Club
gang I never be I'm never going to be
able to look at a golf club the same way
is that a clicker
[Applause]
yeah I'm wearing these headphones
wrong this mon has headphones not me I
don't I wouldn't wear cringy headphones
like
[Applause]
that it's a little hard to understand if
they see you or not cuz they make so
much noise
anyway there's definitely more in the
other room
right
yeah there's one
more and there's Runners
too name it l Diablo
[Applause]
why all right let's keep
going uh you're in the [__] way
all right what do we
got damn so many of
[Applause]
them all right which way are you going
to
[Applause]
go walk
please is he coming up here
[Applause]
walk
[__] all right I'm just going to
hope that actually actually look okay
it's safe to kill him
now where'd he go
oh hopefully the zombie is not oh oh no
oh
no
okay we'll go in
here next
room nice and selfy since the easiest
way to do
this close
one close does not kill the
Bunny come on
man all right this [__] is going go
you dead you Mama
dead don't worry about me we got another
clicker in
there all right we'll take that one out
next I hide behind chair chair gang CH
gang that one actually had a face it
might have been real so will she see me
here I I'm still confused cuz they said
they were blind but then they saw
me maybe I made too much
noise it's
confusing oh there's another one right
there oh we should probably take that
out
[Music]
first
oh this is
spooky this is a little
creepy I'm not going to toggle my
flashlight
now clicker didn't hear
anything dumbass
[__] why didn't you go clicky clacking
somewhere else
huh clicker more
like what a [__] you
hurt you hurt
yeah coming for your ass
boy yeah nice cover Dena dumb
[__] oh come look at
Dina e they're so slimy hey blanket
nice yeah
hway
clear we just got the other room to
worry about this one more I'll take
it AI gets smarter later in the game
sure hope it
does oh oh
[Music]
no [__] that was
close [__]
you're
dead it doesn't L yeah I don't see how
they would get smarter like they would
intentionally make them
Dumber all right I think that was
it better be gas in here boy is that it
I think so
yes go team [__] says go team did
nothing I'm full all right crafting time
on a jury but it was fun sit down yeah I
meant to do that look at evidence try to
tell if somebody's lying we make a Molly
just give me five minutes of my knife I
tell you if they were lying or not oh
wow okay I not used to the controls
yet okay check in here
I'm not going to loot around
everywhere hey little help coming should
I should I look more I can't
tell oh my
bad well now I definitely won't look
around more God damn it
you ever been to a courthouse before
nope you're telling me you never got in
trouble back in Boston oh I got in
trouble but never courthous goddamn
blankets what is this
this
ooh some serious [__] went down here
stun bum St multiple enemies then finish
them off with strike attacks kind of
like shooting them in the knee I
suppose
preso is there music being
played parking garage well the gas is in
there right well that's what the notes
say
well let's get down there let's go
Gamers I have to shake up the flashlight
okay I was like
what nope the bottle
please and we grab another
one just like that
[Music]
yeah there's a shotgun in the
bank oh I don't know the code
yet let's find
it in here maybe prep a survival guy for
the silent
majority uhhuh Todd Garrett wrot it
yeah
you can't open
it now oh okay so I learned stuff from
the survival guy now I can make bombs
that's
[Music]
funny excuse
me so now I can craft melee upgrades
craft an upgrade for your melee weapon
restoring it to fully durability and
greater increases damage that seems
pretty useful need 20 pills I got six so
I should definitely start looting more
although we're just at the start of game
apparently this game is like 20 5 hours
or
something 69420 you guys are funny you
guys are real comedians
huh people are saying it's
02055 I'm sure it can't be that [__]
hard to find
it Isaac Dixon
with the Patterson and Sanchez gone
Dixon has top PRI Target
okay reminder all confiscated from
suspect should be placed in the office
lock of codus well I guess you were all
wrong 86
0722 86
0722 it's right there as
well should I grab this this might come
in handy
it can't be 86 722 that's too
easy I cannot be [__] to read all that
this guy was a fedra commander or
something they were losing to the wlf
and trying to
escape how big is this group if they
were able to beat the Army you don't
need a lot if you're that
vicious we need to be careful let's just
be safe why he's dead what do you mean
okay
Jesse all right we got a machete now 86
0722 I don't believe this is
it incredible
incredible that was nearly impossible to
figure that out
Jesus all right so now we can
upgrade
um craft melee upgrades I feel like I
want to learn
that so now we got machete and
[__] and no
bottles we have
machete
appreciate uh just a big shout out
to R8 Cobra you're banned you gave me
the wrong code before ban I don't [__]
around you're done capish
fenito this ain't no game you don't try
to troll me with no
consequences small peee your penis is
cut off now hope you're happy snip snip
[__] Benny the VF is winning the
city is going to fall any day now up
recently okay those people were just
trying to get food for their families
and they would start banishing people
for station that's a def sense
listen all right away yourself I
guess judge full mush Ellie be all right
we're
cool
I'm not sure where to go this is the
main entrance isn't it that would make
sense cuz we went down and
then so I assume we have to go here yeah
she's doing
something should I push
her I pressed x what the hell okay
careful so garage got to be down
right
yep
hello there's going to be zombies in
here for
sure oh we got
water [__] oh
wow all right it's shooting time
I can't do well in
panic let's get the
clicker shoot that
[__] yeah
[__] night night
[__] watch this watch this oh God it's
not
help me you're welcome where the
clicker got
him got
him I'm done I'm done I'm
done I'm done shoot her please shoot her
shoot her she's crazy you're missing
everything thank you dumb
[__] hi why can she miss so much huh I
have 100% accuracy and this is how you
do it Jesus Jesus Christ I think that's
all of
them those fig guys never even made it
out of the garage damn 100% accuracy FL
ging find that gas someone of them
dropped something but I don't see
it well I suck at aiming I'm not
climbing back up over
here stor Trooper level accuracy thanks
guys it was Dena though though come
on I love how they keep making the same
mistake of entering a place that has
zombies that gets them locked up before
checking if they're moving how do they
survive this long you guys
stink yeah I want to see more giraffes
getting drawn as well okay here we
go Jack told me the gameplay gets really
good and wait I'm looking forward
got gasoline our Luck's changing don't
you jinx us if you put it in your mouth
you can carry more of
it I know see they make so many mistakes
[__] Federate is calling to
us well how do we get out of
here thanks for the reminder I forgot I
could do
that
thank you zto creations sorry I'm not
reading donations but I'll check it out
later we can't go back the same way we
came has to be another entrance found
it I love the gameplay of Uncharted and
it is fairly similar with the stealth
aspects and all
that
am I
blind why don't I see a way
[Applause]
out I don't see a
way out of this
place my
[Music]
Sho what the [__] is
there was a chain on the door thanks
guys see I like this shoot the
tank that's not a bad
idea I'm kind of
curious [__]
it all
right that's not it I don't need a hint
game I know what I'm
doing
you pull this
valve there was a chain on the
door damn
it oh oh here's the chain got
it Dina big
brain
[__] come
on sorry game over [__]
okay let
go good job babe
thanks babe hey y just judging us okay
gate could be a while before we run into
Abby and her friends it might be worth
grabbing some supplies before we press
on yeah you said that last time and you
then you played a
song for hours onward
Shimmer um
we could also check out the restaurant I
I'll leave it to to you guys restaurant
or no say yes yes yes or no no no you
same miss having a roof over my head you
know Forest let's go it's right here up
a farm just outside of Jackson why
wouldn't you stay in town I don't know I
like the idea you guys said yes too
sounds lonely only if you're doing it
let's punch it
okay so are we going to like raise sheep
and melt cows are you making fun of me
yes no it actually
sounds kind of nice really yeah okay
there's a safe
here
okay could I have flip that
note wasn't Joel all about talking
kidding me he trade half his stuff for a
bag of beans I never got it tastes like
burnt [__] oh now you've gone too far
[__] quied taste my
ass what the
hell isn't coffee really big in Seattle
isn't it I remember that when I was
there hey big blue
[__] mhm
mhm m
m
m all right where's the Vault he's
here
[__]
it
it's so much I'm so used to aiming for
the head but it's so much better to just
shoot them in the
knee yeah how did they get inside these
places he just had the poopy come on I
hate that
[__]
baros Marion and
sixth all right a new place to head out
huh
let's go
Gamers did I miss anything here oh my
God sorry
guys making some
notes hey found a
key it says bar goes on it might be
worth checking
out don't tell me what to do but yeah
we're going there for sure oh it's
nearby uh he behind us next to that
other
place gotcha should we get this gas back
to the [__] fedra gate yeah so it's
behind this building am I
crazy kind of we go straight and then
right now I grabbed the ammo from the
gun there was nothing
else don't worry Gamers I know what I'm
doing
Seattle is a cool
City a cool
setting don't why I keep checking the
map
so
excessively let's go up here we go here
we go here we go here we go one
two no entrance then want that
point we got a fire truck on the bridge
that's pretty epic can you stop checking
the map every 3
seconds yeah I'm
sorry let make sure I don't get
lost oh here it
is leg
broke deliver is in the rear that's got
to be it
I know all about them rear deliveries am
I right
Gamers
yeah braing so large got a
sixpack don't I
surprise what the hell is this place
some kind of wlf
something we got
blood there got to be a lot of supplies
then we got uh what's this these are
plans to hit a fedra con boy this place
must be
old yeah I don't think anybody's been
here in years yeah we could take a look
pills here
yeah we can go here and then we can go
here and then we can go here and then we
can forget about Joel and then we can
get it B your
f what is that don't worry about it wlf
propaganda reminds me of the fireflies
in Boston in New Mexico we have these is
there tinkering station here maybe
Protectors of the Constitution they call
themselves all right let's do some
crafting so I can craft an upgrade for
the
thing okay craft another bomb
no Med
kit and then let's see what we got on
pills we got
35 we need
40 did you want something cuz I wasn't
listening what is
this o we can holster two guns now
right
goon and ghost would have loved this
sweet I guess I got to talk um
who they were these feral cats I have
before I came to Jackson but they didn't
seem to want to leave with us so I miss
those scratchy little [__] sometimes
yeah you have any pets you missed them
in it never really my thing well maybe
when we're done with all this we can get
a nice little creature to take care of
all right
deal why am I aiming at the I wasn't I
was aiming in case there was zombie
behind her
Gees you think I'm that
crazy we're reminded of where we're
going I did not mean to do that I was
trying to check the
map where's horsey
here
boy here
boy hell little boy where the [__] did
he
go can you Wizzle like in Zelda oh there
you are what you up to go you're get
sm hey you nervous at all nope about
after everything we found out about the
wlf they seem so we got two new
locations jeez Louise
just means we have to be more careful
where should we check know we're coming
for him exactly uh there's a shotgun in
the bank I don't see a bank on the map
right now all right we should get back
to the [__] fedra gate before we lose
the day yeah see if we can find those
wlf at the
Cina so there
was we go left then okay I check the map
as many times as a goddamn please
this looks like a
bank but which building is
it let's check in
here no that's close for sure and that's
the
gate that's the
DHL
is there an entry squeeze through bit
where you G come on there's something
back
here another safe what's the code the
map of
us use the gate code oh okay uh we have
that how do I open all my
documents
uh
here we
go [__] we I forgot to check which gate
we were East
5345 now we did that
already gate
West one second
Gamers uh
okay
damn what
happened what
happened that I not do
it do something bug
out why am I
stupid both equally
likely yeah big
brain yes we got another card guys some
good
[Music]
scavening
so is that crossed off the map now no I
don't want to read
this we got 55 which means we can
upgrade crafting speed which I don't
think is that
necessary but 100% is very
fast sorry
okay so that's checked off that's
checked off now we should go to the last
spot and then we'll go to the
gate
yes
see I kind of wanted to check that out
anyway did I get it
right no I
didn't it's up
here is it down
there yeah I check map just to be safe
shut up shut
up
all
right what do we
got
fascists you goddamn
fascist did you guys know fasion some
bad um
oh yeah well why did they give me loot
then who told
you this guy was an
officer traveling a russan
truck trying to hide maybe
unsuccessfully yeah sure looks that
way we got a little note from
them sorry we were wrong everything in
place we be waiting all
right
uhhuh that's
it I need a crafting
table all right yog sman we out
Seas stop
riding oh we got another one are you
[__] kidding
me no we
didn't
we're good she took that long to just
draw one line if the stream is lagging
try refreshing I can't control what
YouTube servers
work um okay so we make a left and then
we go down and then we Bing and then we
bong we Bing and we bong and we whip out
a s and
we it's
nice
yes bank is on six
Avenue well that was an adventure okay
so which block then if the top one is
one where the top question mark is and
then that's 2 3 4 5 6 going down which
number is the bank on thought we'd see
one I guess it's one out of
three
one or eight the top one would be
one six on Columbia oh it's right here
thank
you g go this
skull hey
skull whoa check out the
tank yeah that is a
tank there's something on top of it can
I go
in can we drive it all the way shoot dab
in the face I've never seen one of these
in
action yikes
shotgun ammo this guys had a bad day
that's a good call what is it burnt
skeletons not how I'd want to go
out kind of like those
astronauts what are you talking about
one of the early Moon missions there was
an electrical fire in the astronauts
that's a weird jump to make capsule well
at least they died for something
worthwhile exactly these guys were just
[__] killed by other [__]
spoiler Eli's
Joel Apollo one it was Apollo
one rest in
peace uh so we found the ammo but I
don't know where the shotgun
is the riding is so weird it seems like
they're trying to force in stuff a
little bit I would say I didn't feel
like this playing Uncharted for
example what you got
there someone should make a compilation
of all the
politics cuz one by one it's not a big
deal I think it's totally fine but it's
just so much of it that it's just okay
yeah all right
okay I feel like if they made a
compilation of all of it it would show
kind of how overbearing it's
been
um I needed to check my map not my
journal top right on the map go to V
La do I need to be on Jurgen to look at
the
map
okay so well there's something down
there as well now [__] there's so much
to
explore I want to get the
shoty that's the
bank guess that would make sense let's
try it was it over here
yeah oh my
God a
sign I think we found a bank should we
go explore it yeah let's let's get the
shotty
whoa hello this is cool in like a holy
[__] we might get crushed way
relax been like this for
years I think not a
fan I mean yeah if there's a if we get a
shotgun there's definitely going to be a
big shootter oh
jeez this [__]
man are they all clickers theying body
armor
sexy
no they're not all clickers
[__] so that's a which ones are
clickers oh we got seen we got seen for
sure over there
run wait we got it made it out
all right I'll take
it I think we have to deal with that
Hunter
Last oh there it
is so he's the
[Applause]
problem they can see when they click
what that's so cool that's really
helpful thank you that clears up a lot
of
confusion I guess it's like they send
out like bats yeah like bats you know
bats all right let's get this
guy
wasn't there a thing where this type of
fungus actually
exists it it was like on a I don't
remember where I saw it but it was on an
animal or
something all right let's wait for him
to come
here
hello good
night
BBC Earth yeah it was on an insect right
so disgusting on our left see with 2020
I believe anything can happen [__]
it
where there only two left right is that
what she
said
oops it's like a parasite
yeah all right we're waiting for this
[__] come here yeah girl come on sexy
mama I can make clicking
noises
[Music]
you dead
[__]
yeah oh she did something nice all right
I like Thea now finally [__] H thank
you thank you is it dead is it
dead okay yeah that's all of
them God well we found the bank what's
with the body
armor they don't look like
soldiers yeah not
sure um I did not mean to do
that ell like over the moloto
crazy floor gang immune from an virus
subscribe to floor again become member
instant immunity from zombie infection
trust me guys trust me on this
one now where the
shy hey more blankets hell
yeah I assume in
here creepy
creepy zombies be sleepy
[Music]
sleepy 60
2306 I think these body armor guys were
trying to rob the bank
oh [__] it's like that movie which one
the one with the surfer bank robbers oh
yeah what movie are they
referencing what [__]
movie here we
[Music]
go
oh
[Music]
almost
C Point Break ke reefs Keana Reef
reference all right this game gets a 10
out of 10 for me
now this game has earned my 10 out of 10
official floor gang seal of approval if
there's K big chungas
references
well
done are any zombie hey what's up girl
give me that that's mine
now
mine so do you get a shotgun later in
the game or is that your only chance to
get one it can't be the only chance I
get behind [__] this what supposed to be
here [__] near me and said police and
my own guys lock me in here look at all
this m [__] cowards the bag's full
man if we were back in the old world we'
be
rich yeah and Joel would be
alive
what is this type of shotgun
called long shotgun what whoa whoa
whoa better be better better what the
[__] where the hell did they come
from don't worry dena's got this she's
in the perfect spot there's no way there
there's no way this will not be a
[Applause]
problem Oh Dena you're going to die
watch out
please which one do I go
[Music]
for
oh jeez
Louise I forget they they don't see
Dena all right where did she
go let's do a stealth Corner Meme
here the oldest trick in the book where
do you come from by the way huh where
the hell did you come
from Pro Gamer move right there hey she
got tape on her thanks tape
lady I think we're done with this place
she starts to be in the
credit tape
[Music]
lady no don't don't do that
Jesus all right that's enough [__]
about in
Seattle
that's about that's about everything you
can do in Seattle by the way in case you
ever
visit hey if you lived in the old world
what would you buy with all that money I
don't know maybe a big Farmhouse but you
can get a farmhouse
now okay what would you get a space
shuttle oh that's right your astronaut
thing hey it's cooler than a
farmhouse Farmhouse is way more
practical that place was
crazy I got a shotgun out of it so not
complaining all right okay let's get
back to the [__] feder
gate should I go to the VF
place or [__]
fedra I'm kind of tired I want to I want
to progress feel like we done every
little single thing you could
do you go through
here is there a side quest where they
play
um Rick Ashley
instead cuz I'm down for that
[__]
wait we're right
here where's the
gate is it is it literally this oh my
God it
is so we needed the power that was it we
did all that for that
Jesus blind gang click
gang all right let's juice these up here
we
go look how good Jurgen looks all right
I got it you put in the code thanks for
doing something appreciate
it hey these old generators are pretty
fin might take you a few tries so gate
East two sorry go nothing
uh 5345
okay I thought I remember
you these are janky as hell 5
three
four b
boom well no welcome move or they're
just waiting for
us let's look for a way
in keep an eye on those
windows all right we're entering the
Sarina
Hotel very
cool wolf
wlf I get it oh yeah you see that whoa
infected just hop that fence oh means we
can get in that way what the hell
shouldn't we hear gunshots or
something I don't know what's going
on I don't know
Danny here it comes what does that
mean
cozy damn it's so
cool this
wait what what
comes don't spoil anything what's about
to happen I'm
scared what's
[Music]
happening this is zombies
guys
are they eating something they're
preoccupied there's one in
here oh we missed
him we'll get him
here surprise
[__]
you
dead cuz there's one more moping around
and then there's two [__] them
out let's s a bunch of stuff here maybe
we can throw a bomb in there that might
be
cool
or
moloto let's do a bomb how does the bomb
work all right let's wait for him to
stop there hey zombies what's for them
oh they didn't
die oh this uh this is not his
plan
we'll shoot him in the knees we'll shoot
him in the
[Applause]
knees oh okay they're dead never mind
okay that's
that it's a stun bomb L God oh I know
that now I should have done that
before that's
funny
that's
fun hey little
girl this one's fresh and he's got one
of those wolf
patches yeah guess they didn't make it
out with their gas after all yeah that's
good right those [__] who killed Joel
got taken out by some random infected
why can't I grab the tap and they still
be dead excuse me I'm trying to know
that's
Justice might as well grab what we can
we're
here the stun was awful [__]
useless so much better with the moloto
no I want the
tape
yoink
what we got some coffee whales another
whale reference I was waiting for
that I was waiting for all right good
job we can make another one
Molly popping
mollies put it away
Ellie we got dog Golden dogs you're
getting
one now I mean s no one cuz s never died
but it could have
been nothing I said
nothing I missed alcohol at the
counter wait hold
up the other
counter
what the [__] are you guys
smoking I got it already yeah you got
refresh your browser cuz it might be
delayed for you
guys it should be very little
delay all right what do we got shot you
recognize him no
maybe someone else killed these guys the
infected just wandered
in seems
likely don't mind me
Dina
yo
NADA which I want a
bla
hey found their gas well if we need any
more we know where to get
it that would be such a hoarder if I it
it was a
zombie
apocalypse normally I'm a
minimal okay so we can go up but let's
search the floor
first doesn't seem like there's anything
happening can I squeeze through here
nope
blanket oh a lot of pills
sweet now we can upgrade uh should we
upgrade what should we
upgrade more health or crafting speed
but later Sun bombs become smoke bombs
add a smoke screen craft more effective
H
kits uhhuh or we could just save it for
something better I think more
Health yeah
uh I don't need it cuz I never die
anyway in case you're new you guys
agreed on more Health that's cool but
um it is what it is man I'm so glad I'm
playing this live it's so much more fun
being interactive with you
guys uh I don't really
care
all right now we get the tape why is
there bucket in here someone likes to
take [__] showers huh I respect that I
respect any man that takes [__]
showers oh somebody's going to
definitely be in
here yep
[__]
no who that what the [__] happened in
here Tommy did
this
this no way oh really so he's ahead of
us he one of the ones that killed
Joel hell yeah knock him out one by
one can't wait for Debbie Debbie to
die that's literally [__] over
here
7302 I don't recognize
him he was using him against each
other epic Tommy my
man Joel told me about this
you ask this guy a question but you
don't make him say it you make him write
it
down then you ask this
guy and if the facts match we're telling
the
truth if not you [__] him
up
yeah that's pretty smart I need to
remember
that
East one another gate code looks like
it Tommy's local man Tommy badass
happened now I want to shake that man's
hand you can't be far
off
yeah why are they acting surprised you
you went on the same Mission don't act
so oh I'm so shocked big she were going
to kill him too
right uh okay so we can get out this way
73 to okay remind
me yeah
yeah uh I like the
machete can I see the durability yeah it
looks like it's fine no reason to
swap and we're done gamers we jump down
Gamers damn it looked like she was Free
Falling Juran my
man I know you said Tommy had a rough
pass but [__] I know there was upstairs
oh [__] you're right I forgot about
that it wasn't pretty I don't want you
to think bad of Tommy Ellie if I had my
sister's Killers tied to a
chair I'd do
worse I hear
you
should we check out the
VF there's an AK upstairs are you
serious why didn't I go
upstairs are you trolling
me all right all right someone oh what's
your name what's your name who was the
first one that said
it
Giani Rodriguez ver says there's an AK
upstairs you
Ronnie if there's no AK van and penis
snip
incoming so let's check it
out yeah let's cut up people are saying
that there's no AK in he's trolling cut
off his
dick put him in the
stool put him in the gilo
team nice going Jani [__]
off you're done small peep for
life it goes on the wall of
peee worse than any Wall of
Shame
how the [__] do I go
down
oh isn't this where we came
from sorry where are we supposed to
go we're supposed to go to
V that would make sense at
least then we literally done everything
too okay so there was a gate here right
yeah okay got
it which fortunately will have power on
it you get the generator I'll open the
gate remember the code the one Written
in Blood okay thank God I don't have to
remember another code
nice got it yes and I forgot
it
this question though where does this
take us peee
land cool how the weather changed I like
that say we find shelter and we set up
camp there's a lot of great stuff about
the game high up so we can scope out the
area I like that idea uh especially the
map I really like the map for an open
building I really think the map is
probably the one of the greatest feature
of the game so far wolves I just can't
help myself looking at some of those
almond things left if you're
hungry not really does Ellie ever eat oh
my God what I sounded like my mom just
know I'll be fine
just looking around for the
building if they kill the horse I am
uninstalling the
game I hope they
understand that certain things are just
going too
far why I can't go in the VF
building yeah I wish there was a [__]
mini map
I guess we'll just keep going
in look for a place to sleep sleep Jesus
[__]
Christ what the [__]
no
no I said it 5 second ago h un
install you [__]
what I want install I'm done I'm
done
[Music]
delete
no oh you taking it too far Last of Us
you're taking it too [__] far
now
[__] I'm
shaking I'm so angry see you
again they rob me for every good thing
in the game how'd you find us
asked about a dude with a [__] scar
across his face it's
[Music]
funny how many came with you
H just you
two you can't stop this hey that's the
trailer
Jordan the [__] timing on that
supposed to be out looking for the other
one the [__] is
this you know The Smuggler that we
killed out in Jackson
[Music]
yeah this girl was there what so Joel is
a smug us that's why Nick was [__] up
like that we got to get her to Isaac we
got to tell him exactly what's going on
yeah well I just got off the radio with
Isaac and we got a new mandate [__] this
game hold up hold up hold up that Sho
make it over with what else let's talk
to her let's figure out what she knows I
don't give a [__] what she knows you saw
what she did to the others you have no
idea how many people might be with this
might be an ambush I don't care how many
people she's with we will find them we
will kill can you just think for
yourself for a quick second right
now oh Dena
nice oh maybe not so nice
[Music]
Dina maybe don't stand on the glass next
time Dina just to Pro
tip should come
here
Dina am I supposed to grab the
knif
nope cut cut cut cut cut cut cut cut
cut cut cut cut cut cut C cut
cut can they at least giving me a chance
to save the horse instead of Dena you
know what I
mean oh you dead oh I'm sorry oh damn
Ellie
[__] why would they shoot the horse
there was no reason to shoot the horse
are you
okay
mostly Ellie I I am so lost we should go
somebody would have heard the
gunshots look she's one of them come on
look at that later was there a TV
station on that map I don't [__] know
come on [__]
Ellie yeah [__]
Ellie hey there's a gun right there's a
gun right there go
around go
around
okay ow
Jesus there we go thanks
Dena let's go yoink how many guys did
you
see enough we got to get the hell out of
here bro you don't look so good
bro Jesus that's
Twisted all right let me look around a
little
bit did they take my shotgun away they
better not there we go
what else we
got kind of cozy oh there we
go I don't want to pick them up mid
battle then I get forgot about him
so all right look all green and [__]
it was this way Mo up clear the
rooms yeah they didn't see me
right I go this
[Music]
way I have super saer
hearing what Dina for [__] sake
Straight
Ahead
whoa sorry
[__] my console
battery
surprised [__] there's so
many this gun is
amazing don't shoot on the left oh
[__] excuse
me um let just reload and then your
other KN yeah
yeah yeah keep crying
[__] uh how do I use it this is the
problem with me never having any combat
cuz now I don't know all right I don't
know how to use any stuff so I have the
medkit how do I use
it is she alive
I'm going to find you I'm going to find
you okay oh my
God I'm going to find
you any of guys din is invisible I love
it Jesus
[Laughter]
Christ where are they I can't see them
dude the way you shoot up the arms this
game is
gross okay I need to figure out how I
use healthcat I think it said R2
right there we go I keep mixing up R1
and R2 cuz my brain is so
large so I can't pick that
up
man that was
funny is wor going through these rooms
see what they
got do a quick
scavenge we got empty books that's
cool it's cool the game gives you many
options of way oh
hello oh some snacks a protein bar
make it up
please all right there going to be more
combat for
sure so I only have one of these left
maybe I should swap weapon
then prepare for
shy
watch
it everybody down here
now [__] those shots come from I don't
know search the courtyard you hold the
cafeteria I'll cover here right yeah
split
up surprise [__] shut
up shut up
[__]
yeah wa you friend go [__] so the other
guys in
there and then the third
guy is
open hello a lot of supplies
here
should I toss a bottle God there's so
much
loot feel like we should just snipe them
out this takes too
long look at him I'm so scared look my
gun is literally sticking
out yeah walk backwards in
here
you'll never find me surprise
[__] oh are they seeing
me oo a lot of stuff here up there more
of them okay good thing we were stealy
then Coco
Coco oh I'll give you a new
Poco see if we can make it to the
[Music]
grass oh this is
bad
sh come here come here come here come
here come here come here come here
thought I saw someone you didn't see
anything holy [__]
trespasses how did she shoot me through
the [__] wall
a oh my God why is she so slow God damn
it all right let's get
this reloading
a well that's too
bad is that
it nope
where where am I
oh
I'm blind my
bad [__] there's a lot of them I told
you thanks for saving me by the way Dina
appreciate
it what's the delay is the delay from me
talking and showing up or is the delay
between me and uh the game
play
cuz when you say say delay I don't know
some people say no
delay there's
no could be the servers in your
area or
something pretty fun I like the game
play
I like it a
lot it's like Uncharted uh reskin
gaml yeah there's definitely another
shootout happening here
here [__] these wvs steal their [__]
what do they
got
oh well I Don't Mind If I Do
what do we got oh no told you Ellie get
down
hello hello Adrian's
Patrol [__] hey you press is gone what
you seen anything no cover this roof
I'll check over
here you sure she's not on the street
did you look how would did she get down
there I don't know oh
[__] been called in Greg went out to C
my bad thanks
din we're going to stab them in their in
their
ankles okay so he's over there she's far
away I'm witha and I'm very gay
hey down
there
which one should I take out
first that's
great
[__] I want him to come back damn it I
missed the
chance they're so far away
now come
back are they all
leaving
okay guess that's an option
too [__] [__] I would have closed
this door but that's
just that's just me
man I wish I had a crafting
station it's been so long
man let's Mak some
Molly with the
alcoholic
oh no do they have the
[Music]
key why would it be locked
otherwise oh okay what about
this let's try
it yeah [__]
it
[Music]
no how many people are watching right
now I'm curious cuz I can't see
it throw Molly oh wait there's a dog I'm
not shooting the
dog I a shooting dogs I'm ending the
game we got to get away from this school
now yeah now I ain't doing
anything I saw something
85 dope let's get it let's get to
69 let's get
it come on right in the pee
PE can I not climb over
this damn we have a lot of supplies more
than I can
use is it worth healing
up this is a tinkering station
please I must have missed all of
them I'm
okay I'm
okay nice
place
this is me when I see floor gang need to
get Street
ow yeah ooh random kitchen
drawer Big Boy ammo [__] shoots off
arms another
PlayStation hell
yeah perfect pitch what's the secret
Silver Screen word Clash my favorite
game Ducks Dolan dark be like 10 out of
game what do we got all right Coast
looks clear sweet
yeah I think we're good all right check
this out why are there no Xbox in this
universe this is so
weird she's one of them
well [__] her then read the
letter Jordan Isaac's got us posted up
on a two we at the TV station scars
spotted in the area here's something to
hold you over
Leah we going to the TV station TV
station you think she's still
there we got to find out
right I suppose so
let byy all these tall
[Music]
buildings that
way
okay let's go get
Leah uh should I reload nah nah that's a
noob tactic to reload when you need to
reload but if it makes you feel better
I'll do a little reload
you know what I
mean you know what I'm saying tape
here
alcohol
nothing
hey is that a bro fist is that a mother
flipping bro fist hell yeah 9-year-old
room confirm is that a
goat hell oh yeah whoa almost missed
that
yoink yoink oink
[__] God damn the game looks so
good it's a shame they killed everything
I loved in the
game rest in peace uran we need to have
a hold the funeral they're acting like
they don't even care that's what bothers
me the
most the main character of the game just
died again
yeah thought I was [__] back
there thanks for the Save By the way of
course reload my machete I'm sorry I'm
sorry guys I [__]
up so those are the Wolves they're
really
armed yeah they are do you think there
were going to be this many of them Tommy
said this was a possibility
does that change anything for you
no keep an eye out for
patrols try to smoke your dodging skills
yeah how many I passed too but I got a
feeling there were
more cool so now we have to walk on foot
I miss the oran so much I can't believe
it they'll be out in force looking for
us not a dog be like hey you love this
thing well it's dead
now oh how about this you like this
thing that we oh it's dead and it's dead
it's dead now they're worse than my
Minecraft let's
play all right this looks
cool another PlayStation
no it'd be cool if they had a
PlayStation 5 in it I don't
know I know it's supposed to take place
after but since the game came out just
now and the reveal it would have been
kind of
cool Dina fresh
blood oh I am ready let's get the big
gun that's enough got
him yeah
[__] oh my heart's racing same same that
was
crazy they warned us it was going to
happen and then it
happened wish they warn me of the other
things in the
game all right so how many pills do we
have
now uh 51 we need 40 to upgrade listen
mode move much faster in listen mode
enough that's kind of good
should I go for that I feel like that's
better
than the other
moon what do you guys reckon yeah say
yeah listen mode it is
Gamers this a mirror
work sup what's out [__] who you
talking to you talking to me
[__] what you doing there
Ellie what you doing there in the
shadows what you doing Ellie Ellie stop
it Ellie stop stop
it La be like I'm immune also
Ellie I'm just [__]
around I'm using the
machete we did all of
that what about this
room cool still
fun wish Jan was here you
know
something keeps bugging me why didn't
they kill you and Tommy when they had
the
chance I don't know it seems
Reckless maybe they're
dumb
maybe that must have been a reason could
be that you just weren't who they were
looking for so they let you go yeah well
they did beat the [__] out of us the one
guy Jordan kicked my face in yeah but
why do you think that they didn't finish
it doesn't matter no it matters [__]
up I want to hear what Dina has to say
about
it it matters a great
deal what was the name of the girl in
the note Debbie the one in the TV
station Leah all right was she the one
uh she the one with the braid no that's
Debbie only thing I remember about her
was the sound of her crying over that
sadistic [__] face when I sliced them
open
debie so how do you want to handle
her find know what she knows find out
where the others are from
there you going to ask her why they did
it
yeah oh don't tell me we're going to
spare them or some [__] memories of
stuff Joel said about his
past they're dead nothing new what are
the chances he did stuff that you don't
don't know about
hi he wasn't um wasn't very big on
sharing I'm big on
sharff I wonder what Tommy's making of
all this you probably know more about
all the people Joel AC
crossed huge on
chairs
yeah all right should I jump this
balcony
there should I have jumped off here
seems like a weird space to
add yeah I think I'm supposed to
jump I can still kind of see the
buildings
go uh let's
see straight towards it well if we had a
horse or something we could have
probably oh
no
man this is huge
where this is so big I I wish I had a
horse you
know
[__] what [__]
no
ah
[__] no I'm
not they see me oh God
hey
there boy oh boy did I [__]
[Music]
up
someone else sees me right here no no
you don't see me you
didn't you didn't see me but here I am
you can't shoot me I'm
invisible
oops Jesus
nice take a shi pill take a shield
pill where are they coming
from
relax are you
evil get the [__]
back well I think that went pretty
well I don't think
so
good [__] I'm playing on normal
difficulty you recognize any of
them none I mean hardest I'm playing on
harness man this Q is huge right it's
pretty massive nailed it you think the
world will spread out all over it I sure
hope
not but it seems a bit easy it was
really difficult in the beginning when I
wasn't used how the gaml was
let's check out nany's knicknacks
see what we got maybe some unlockable
outfits in the
game anything in here just Halloween
stuff some of this stuff is funny
looking yeah I literally just pick up a
blanket torch go dangling
haha is there any way to turn off the
blur when you move the camera it's a bit
annoying
what do you
think reload your punches I'm
sorry yeah it's a I see what people like
it but it's a bit G for the eyes
maybe if I wasn't playing on a if I was
playing on a TV probably would be
nicer there got to be a workstation in
here it just has
to I have have so many [__] nooks and
shits [__] I'm
full yeah
nice
oh sweet what do you guys think we
should upgrade I really like their
revolver less recoil more stability
reload
speed upgrade jeel I can't he's dead
asking for a
trans [__] don't do it
man be a good opportunity beat up on
those [__] get FaceTime with
Isaac
whoa oh this is
bad all right
I'll app let me give you some advice
though shoot get the information and be
done with it don't get carried away get
up am I
right oh yeah I forgot they can't see
Dina I don't know what's the
best way to approach this so This Guy's
along is he coming in here oh no
hey Senor we're just a couple girls
we're just a couple girls behind the
desk and you can't see us for some
reason
sh oh they see me no they
don't invisible Dena strikes
again oh I've got them don't shoot here
don't shoot I'm
innocent
godam I said I was innocent did she not
guilty on proven guilty can you move
[__] can you [__]
move get closer yeah get closer
please oh
God wish I had upgraded my gun before
this all right just
take it easy just take it easy okay I'll
take it easy I'll take it really
easy damn
[Music]
Ellie you don't [__] with
me all right you don't ever [__] with
me how many guys did they send looking
for
you too many I can put a 6X scope on
it that's kind of
cool damage seems pretty
good okay
uh do we need to upgrade the
shotgun I want to try the
scope she just pulled that out of
nowhere and let me see there oh there we
go 3D printed that while you weren't
looking
[Music]
yes
no oh
sweet cool we're done for for
now press X while aiming to use your
scope
sweet we'll have some fun with
that uh is it better to get swap bit cuz
this has more
durability I see you
[__]
I could have gone
here use the
machine I'm too rich now Suffering From
Success pills
here
well isn't that
nasty all right let me get get the
machete back
then it's cooler my shed is cooler than
an axe we all know
it reload your ax okay I'm working on
it thought I could slice open in the
penis uh
the
um
the the law yeah okay all right this
looks like an open shop let's go
in loot the lockers there's
lockers dude we can rent
DVDs space saww gu one of my favorite
films of all time where were the lockers
actually needed
that there we
go
wow okay that's actually it
nice thanks
guys gee thanks a
lot
okay enough of
that good boy thanks thank you I
try oh
man I hear
zombie let's snipe hey oh yeah make more
noise please thank you appreciate
it a ton of
zombies a zombie
Patrol should we open this
door feels like a bad idea can you open
it
without is this a door as
well
okay you
can clicker didn't like that
though damn it it closed
again hey hey how you
doing how dides dead feel
like oh God
[Applause]
[Music]
you see
me that was
cool that was really
cool the flash of the gun showing the
face right
before I like that
keep forgetting they can see me when
they
click I mean I didn't forget there was
literally nowhere to hide I didn't see
the spot should have used my
flashlight K's
here yes another
tarot I love video compression in
darkness it looks so
good these wlf guys went up against the
military over a decade ago yes we
getting more upgrades now there can't be
that many trespassers that come through
here I don't know City still looks like
it's filled with supplies I can't see
why people would need to fight over
it craft salzers
so I have to craft
it oh
okay what how how does this look
like how does
this that's so ghetto
dud what the [__]
does that work gun nerds tell me will
that work that would not [__]
work hey
hey yes what [__] off you're lying I
don't trust
you a bottle a
bottle maybe we could head down there
yeah a [__] Coca-Cola
bottle it works dude it would explode
right they stole the idea from Call of
Duty everything is stolen from Call of
Duty every piece of art ever
made that's not fair to
say [__] coca cocacola
bottles just cuz it happens in Call of
Duty does not mean it's real guys just
so we're C
just so we
understand it's a rag inside a bottle
oh well that makes more
sense I read this I think I read it on
the cursed comments the best way to kill
someone silence is to shoot them in the
ass that actually makes sense that I
believe a coke bottle get the [__] out
of here
woo hey we got more Rags should we make
another
silencer I don't really need anything
another moloto
maybe
yeah oh God that scared me oh they're
real [__] soon what the [__] still don't
understand thought it was a mannequin
and we're not falling back we're getting
called up it took us months to SEC this
yeah grab
it it's Coke time
[Music]
[__] this just is this two of
them let's wait for the one of them to
come in
here
I really want to try the
coke
[Music]
[__] dude Coke
Works to your left
rle
where there's teddy
bears oh there we
go good thing we Ed the silencer then oh
[__] I'm going seeing I'm me
seeing
where who spotted
me I know the silencer broke I got to
make another
one
can't is it sniping
time I think it's sniping
time now just sleep little boy careful
now
oh scope
gang
yeah he
lived he lived I shot him in the jaw
dude it's all right it's all right it's
all part of the [__] them
off and he became the
block [__] I messed that up so bad damn
it look at this guy in the window who to
the
right
where you want to greet you want to say
hello I shot
first you
serious they [__] sneak up on me you
snake
that's another
one yeah there another
one surprise [__] you got surprised by
the surprise
[__] yeah Dina you take over I'm
busy should I
heal those head shot though
Aimbot are you
hidden hey oh I'm not [__] sorry all
right now I got to
heal let's see if there's a way around
in um can't really see all right let's
try this
[__]
place somewhere they didn't see
me maybe we can throw a
distraction you think that's them yeah
I'll go check it
out yeah
yeah
yeah all right let's do this
[__] I can't reach damn it it would have
been so
funny oops might have seen them on it
you definitely didn't see
me what you got I got
nothing where are they oh they're
upstairs who sees me someone sees me
it's really confusing where are like oh
oh there [__] we should probably take
him
out
stealth
kill who's
shooting
where I I just want to
loot
am I that crazy can a man just want to
loot I just want to check the toilet for
pills you
know how do I repair the
machete I think it's literally just the
guy upstairs
left I need it needs to be broken
first restore full durability yeah it
needs to be broken
first he's
here reaload the machete add scope to P
really appreciate the in insightful
comments guys really
helpful wow you guys are the best I love
my fans oh my God what would I do
without you you're so no [__] they see
me where
oh [__]
[Music]
clueless reload your
backpack is this
sarcasm oh where's he
going we'll sneak behind
[Music]
him see see how I did that see how I
Snook
oh [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] I'm
bored can you go
away yes come in hello hello come come
come come come look at this dumb [__]
hey hey hey hey gang BL gang in here
boy all right now's the time to strike
bing bang bing bing bing
binging got you ride where want
you woo was he poor he had nothing poor
gang it's you guys no my myy broke yeah
why didn't you tell tell me to repair it
now
what we got to get through this
checkpoint wall those buildings are on
the other side oh my God
guys there has to be a way over I didn't
reload my
machete [__] let's get up to the second
floor everyone told you no I didn't see
a single comment where's they
upstairs
where's the stairs I don't see the
stairs see if we can find
it is there an AK
upstairs we'll find stop crying we'll
find another machete it's all
good f for
machete that that doesn't sound
right M is for
M oh
[Music]
[__] is there just one
guy
sweet hey [__] they was like you can
take
hostage no really no I don't believe
that [__] Dina just appears out of
nowhere and I'm almost like what the
[__] who is
that what's her
name is it Dena
Diana it's di isn't
it
practice hardw Focus oh it ain't it
ain't working out for you guys I'll tell
you that
much okay let's go
here woo legs broke
again reload
gang hey Dina
yeah maybe there's a flashback where you
get to play as Joel you
know her name is l Diablo why give me
your
hand that's the name of my
hey that round building it looks like
the TV station from your map it does
does that building exist in Seattle
Seattle gang
answer I can adjust the straps of my
chair and now I'm more
comfortable reload
gang reload while jumping off gang
yeah I don't know how I would have done
all this without you
[__] what the [__] was that I ran into a
trap a what explosive traps a what a
what you're walking what a trap what is
a trap what is a
trap stupid [__]
sorry I'm running
to watch me walk into one one of the
traps watch
me hey zombie I'm right here oh okay hey
it's
me have you seen my legs sorry
bro uh Dina we're kind of doing a
stealth Mission here this is kind of
awkward that you're standing up I'm
clearly being invisible over here I
don't like the fact that you're just
standing there look how she's judging me
she's totally judging me can you stop it
stop judging me dude I'm stealthing bro
[__] hey all right loot
here I'm so preoccupied while looting
all these places could be identical copy
and paste and I wouldn't have tell a
difference I'm okay not checking the
trading
cards sorry Debs who worked on those
I'm just not
interested all right let's see if we can
distract them over
here cuz those are traps
right W by a
bing boom craft a silencer good call
okay silent gang
scissor
gang we just need a melee and then we
can upgrade it [__] I want to do
it dead gang Double Dead
gang cringe
gang there something
here where you going hey hold on a
second
whoa climbing
gang sniping gang are is pretty cut
up Chanel fancy
gang
oh hell look away look
away
now I understand why this game is rated
10 out of 10 I get it now before I was
ignorant but now I understand it all
makes sense any wolves I didn't see any
but it's hard to
tell I think we got to get down this
okay we've been live for two hours uh
now would be a good time for me to do a
PP break I'll be right back um someone
tell a funny story in the chat and then
I'll
uh
do some
stretching
yo 69 we hit
it hell yeah we hit 69 Gamers [__] yeah
peep
stretch sorry right I'll just going to
have a drink and a quick
snack
and then we're going to stream for a lot
more so don't go anywhere 69
gang it's really fun so far I think the
game is fun to play at least cuz the
combat and all that shit's
fun what do you guys
think I'm going to stream this game a
lot it's really long so game play is
fine
yeah what's L Diablo I don't get
it it's ironic
cuz it seems to suffer a little
bit L theistic gun used in the first oh
[__] that was a Mee from the first game
in
Diablo oh my God you're
right sorry I know it's
loud I'll stream for another couple
hours L Bro [__] sorry guys how could I
forget
um
so what was I
saying sorry it's so
good okay
enough
what does accessibility mode
mean
okay this protein
nuts
oh is that better is this
better whoa look at the detail on that
[__] that's
cool should I have that or
not whoa what why would I do
that why the [__] would I play like that
blood mode that's kind of
cool hey Mr Beast is in
it which one is the
regular thank
you that's pretty
good why
why what the [__] is happening
how do I get out of
this
yes Jesus Christ don't ever want to do
that
again [__]
heck
um okay so we were just up there forgot
what we were doing I think the thing
they suffered a little bit the same
problem that Walking Dead have where
this is cute uh concept of you taking
care of this younger girl and you want
to protect her in the game it's the same
concept but then okay come on the
problem is they do it so they grow up so
a they're not cute anymore and then the
main protector dies so the whole dynamic
is ruined what if she's gone by the time
we get there I don't want to think it
doesn't work
now it loses the appeal right away and
it makes me think did they not
understand what made the game put some
of those trick wires up good from
beginning might be a good way to deal
with the hordes obviously I get that
they want to try something new and not
be pandering but it just feels a bit
much feels almost
spiteful like you know what they expect
this well [__] them we got killed Joel
and then the horse and then we kill that
[__] horse yeah yeah
it's good look write this [__] down who
do you think it
is uh someone who wants us to feel her
love you think she's related to The
Wolves hell
no holy [__] dead these were all shot y
again
no should all y against be for look he
has a j for uran no
no no fact I did a number on this
one
e you okay yeah sorry it's just a
smell all right they even hyped up the
horse riding really
that's you good to keep going yeah I'm
fine [__] I'm eating
please how'd this city get so
wrecked Boston wasn't like this was it
Boston didn't have a full-blown Civil
War fireflies never put up this kind of
resistance crunch see the TV
station no yeah it's that way oh
uphill so hole in the fence
oh more
bodies more shot bodies oh [__] I just
realized came this
way Ella will not procreate a child and
it's the
apocalypse what a double
whammy I mean one whammy one
whammy solid
barricade okay well stop trip
wire stop
listen Bing Bong is in oh whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
infected still whoa whoa whoa [__] I
almost missed them yeah let's be
careful um
[__] we can go through here
right all right let's be careful
here I bet you I'm going to walk into
one of them place your bets ladies and
gentlemen
oh hell yeah it's punching
time did you hear
something is there storage back here
what do we
got
yes I want more ammo of
that let check the
lockers a little disorienting looking
around like I'm doing sorry okay we got
Tinker
station what's next on the list
guys
capacity recall
ability n we don't have that
much I say we wait it ain't
time
I'm so
hungry these nuts are doing nothing for
me we've really got this area
covered probably don't cut through here
much with all this there's that silver
lining [__] nail it all this
stuff
huh
oh wait there can we come from here oh
my God wait I sell
something swear I saw
something stop looking at me
Dina
[Music]
oh oh it's almost six that's why I'm so
hungry should stop
snacking
more
traps can I go around
it
no you be
quiet oh that was that was
taped can we go
here
nope
under
yeah can we open this whoa whoa whoa
careful this my only option to blow this
up it feels like it there's a TV
station
let's do
it smart that works yeah I've seen Joel
do this Joel was the best and I loved
him unlike you was pretty loud keep your
eyes
peeled yeah seems like a bad idea to do
this but hey to each his own
there was a safe back there stay down
there these stairs are wired
up can you detonate
them not
here why [__] May
then looks like we have to go that
way
I grabed my brick and throw
it we're not being subtle right
now maybe Leah will come to us yeah all
right where's the safe we need to Ambush
us who said it who said there was a
safe who there's a safe wait I saw
someone before
say Sir who says there's a safe and I
have to go back sir who is putting his
life on the line it's next to the
AK so uh sir
whom is putting his dick on the on the
gillotin and we're going to
see if it was worth
it
yeah [__] I can't I cannot be bothered
with
these where's the [__] safe
siru let's get
it
H waiting for the safe
reveal you tell me
suu sissor emojis cut cut cut cut
cut it's cutting time it's penis cutting
time and you know
it right
there
in this
building all I'm saying is there better
be a safe in
here or else they'll be cut cut cut cut
cut cut yes yes yes yes yes yes hello
bear
you're
dead don't even try
Anakin yeah oh there is a
safe SE there will be no penis cutting
today congratulations I salute you thank
you for your
contribution well done well done I'm
honestly impressed PP safe PP safe in
the safe we'll unlock it [__] what's the
code [__]
[__] H maybe it's in the
toilet what they that [__]
cat pee
here
okay
no
no why was I not charging
it F's in the chat
boys shut
up I know that that's why why I'm
charging
[Music]
it that
clicker oh my God shut
up charge harder you
know
for [__]
sake people are saying the code is
53133 all right you bet you better be
right cuz
else where where do I find
it
hold
up are you
correct cuz there's a lot of P penis on
the line
here oh well done Lads
thanks that was not worth it are you
kidding me all all right
fine I did
it reload your controller
PES not worth it I suppose the penis
will have to get chopped
anyway
the Council of penis has decided cut cut
cut cut cut cut cut cut cut any ideas
think we can get up there
really
HTO
HTO if I used to be
baby
[Music]
T need to get in
there
really going around
[Applause]
gang hold up let me reload my brick
really quick sorry about that
guys okay it's
reloaded there it is stay
low
why cringe gang feels
empty I don't buy it you see a way
in not
yet found it we could climb
up found the way in
gang jumping down gang breaking ankles
gang put the scope on The
Brak I'll try that next
time made it inside
gang all right all right all right all
right all right all right
all o ladder it's
brutal Tommy do this it's
brutal these girls have no
self-awareness I love
it I can't believe they did this shots
off arms stabs people begging for their
life I can't believe it this is awful oh
lights on
gang ankles go
snip penis cutting go
snip
we need a scissor Emoji better than the
one there
is stealth
gang snack
gang blanket gang alcohol
gang ooh axe finally
sweet yoink
gang
yes
super chup what's ax in Japanese I don't
know
[__]
yes so far we got nothing but they tend
to come out of
nowhere
x
x x is in
by
aisan
how are we on pills by the way
42 move faster while prone yeah that
seems pretty good we'll go with that
next are we supposed to break the
windows and jump
down yeah I I think we can make that
jump uh what about the cable cable gang
blocked off door
gang Ellie what about
that excuse me what about
what what about
what point oh she's pointing at it okay
uh let's see
here what about what what was she
pointing
at
Oh see it that's
funny thank
you oh this is a nice
place I like
this holy cozy it's like Christmas this
is definitely not
Tommy who the [__] did this oh
no
but it's a
message Logan Paul gang this just
happened you think they're still here oh
no I hope not keep your eyes
open is that graffiti
again who are these
guys someone else the wlf they're
YouTubers well they seem [__] derang
I know they're [__]
crazy
messed up man I can't believe guys we
found a dead
body we this will get
viewed why they're really keeping the
tension High here as far as I long we've
been playing this building without
anything
happening and they're giving us all this
ammo and [__] too and there's cover
everywhere too so we're going to meet
someone then we're going to fight it out
here you know it's you know it's
true see I'm full of
ammo yeah it's going to be a big
shootout big big big
big
that's how game works that's how mafia
works just wish something would happen
follow me B
why I'm looking for sissors and
[__]
Cut the
Ropes
why why do
jpeg didn't we literally come from
here
holy [__] we walked in
circles thanks for the tip of following
guess we can go there is that it oh my
god wow they pull a sneaky on us we're
too exposed we have to search all of it
I want to find
Leah just why Cut the Ropes when you can
Embrace
uran they didn't give an option to cut
him all right I'll cut the [__] rubs
all right move
[__] you just picked up scissors you
can do now all right cut rope
gang See
Marshall
cut cut cut cut cut cut cut cut the cut
the cut the cut the cut the cut the cut
wow that's so cool all right all right
I'm going to find whoever [__] told
me to cut the rubs cuz your penis is
chopped off
now you're done you're done you're done
you think I [__]
around all right let's see here all
right who started it who started
it who [__] started it
Lost Boy no yeah it was lost no wait
Scrolls up more Lost Boy you're
done you're done you understand
me you're done chopped off to the wall
of Shane wall of
peee bye Lost Boy bye you're
dead [__] hell
anyone else anyone else want to Lost
lose their pee
PE go right
ahead [__] hell listen to you
guys I'm full of ammo and
everything okay it makes sense actually
now we go here and then the place gets
filled up this is a nice office nice C
nice door here oh my God we have not
used the shotgun ever a single time I've
used a
shotgun oh guys we got the kimimila
trading card should I cut the
robes another body up there
should I cut the should I go back and
Cut the Ropes
case God I cannot be Rother the loot
more I'll just go for it
[__] what is that it's better not be
Debbie cuz she's
mine oh she dead she dead herself hell
that's
her
Leah you sure
yes arrows and Sh the universe really
wanted her dead
huh I she doing hugging her this is what
happens if you don't cut the rope
guys
this is two do you copy six acknowledge
over hey this is
Leah
Dina
H it's all of them dead
gang he
wait that's near
Jackson look at their [__] smiles
yeah [__] you [__] you [__] done
Abby cut the cut the cut
the yeah some killed
[Music]
him I'm getting more into the game I
like it three down right I like a Lo
thing chit three down this is do you
copy kill India in route to the TV
station repeat support India in route
yeah we should get going
oh it's almost like I was right about
everything hell yeah hell yeah I say
horse maybe die horse die I'm prophet
and you know it pissed we couldn't talk
to her Prophet King
yeah she didn't hurt Joel it would have
been [__] up to make her
talk she traveled hundreds of miles to
torture him I don't care whether she
held the club or not I get it
yeah this is a story about being
complicit for sure she dead gang deeper
into
downt building is
secure all right can we shoot some
people [__]
Hy
already my
God
where do we come from was it
here Felix looks comfy oh
absolutely feel good
man keep your open
[__] oh wait wait wait wait
wait if we can get all three of those
dead [__] scars killed them spread
out
we still could have scars in the
building how are we getting out of here
someone get to the radio and call this
in now on me if we can
get a [__] they're already spread out
cutting them down make sure the
building's clear first I'm not leaving
them up there cut them down [__]
cutting them down going to do now
[Music]
go I want to get at least a double if I
waste the
Molly go close cler
guys are they coming
upstairs all right here we go [__]
they're too far away aren't they damn it
don't come
upstairs oh
God invisible
Dena oh I didn't see
you
who's shooting me oh my god
[__]
[__] oh
thanks down keep her
down we're just
chilling surprise
[__] surprise
[__] oh sorry reloading
[__] and he's still
standing I don't think
so that wasn't too bad I hear more this
way damn it come on damn
it where
I want to do some sniping
too oh [__]
there
where Ellie come on uh um sniping
instead God damn it
God damn it I keep getting
hit scope is
useless it's them we got them Ellie
through this window hit them from
behind you're
F burn
gang
Jesus what the [__] just happened
gang oh [__] Tina we got to run that's
that's what em was doing I don't [__]
know show up Don't Stop we got to lose
them uh let me let me just change weapon
let me just let me just hold
up who's
sh
really oh my God all right we got to
run get
ahead just run yeah I I wasn't sure
it'll work for now keep going
going find way
in sewer gang
masks okay zombie
time crawling
game reload
gang lost Bo I'm I'm sorry Felix I
didn't know you can't cut the robes it
was just an idea you said it four times
you said it four
times we got to keep
moving how about maybe cut that in the
road huh how about that your penis is
still on the
wall not
forgiven I'm just [__] with
you or am
I upgrade
machete should I heal what's my hell
yeah let's
heal all right I believe that your
intentions were
pure and you will be removed from Wall
of Shame just because I trust you but if
you
ever ever pull anything
again b
side B freaking side way through I'm
going to reach out to all your sponsors
okay I
know what the [__] happened
here what oh squeeze through thre
squeeze through gang very gracious I
know
hello hey
hey it's all
[Applause]
[Music]
good what the Oh I thought it was a cut
scene I'm like why are we just sitting
here God damn it
whoa this is
cool trespass that looks
amazing [__] I think I'm going to be
seen just leave him down here for the
infected to
eat so we have zombies to worry about as
well oh God it's literally
there
her face dude so
funny I kind of want them to run
into zombies and
[__] careful on our
right they're they're [__] don't push me
out
then
is he coming
[Music]
here [__] how do I do
this oh
God don't mind
me
what's the best line of action
here oh God don't come here you're going
to regret it trust me
dude the hell was that oh did the
clickers come out for that that'd be
cool damn it pick up on us
yes
oh God that's a lot of
them
them surprise
[__] oh God I'm
innocent dude I'm innocent it was not
me
oops they're shooting each other no
that's
Denon Fringe gang
get those
[__] that was a terrible
throw but you
know got
him I'll save his
life
hey over
here
Jesus
[__] what a mess
we shouldn't hang out here for too
long grab what you can over here shoots
his head
off I need to use this weapon more cuz
clearly I'm getting so much ammo
with well the Breck was a good
call I'll save another break just got to
make sure I don't forget to reload it
it's kind of
cringe
man love how this looks
like
incredible
where do we go through the
subway heal I don't need to heal now I
have
plenty
fine wimp
gang
oh you can do it quickly that's
cool dude look at the art Direction so
cool I love
[Applause]
it a come
on could have just grabbed
that what's happening in here
D po
gang I can move this hurry
gang [__] fungus gang come on let's go
so
yeah are you okay yes thank you
yeah
thanks
babe babe I'm really tired babe I'm so
tired yeah let's get out of
[Music]
here
this way's blocked
Jewels B
[Music]
gang I ain't reading
that maybe through
here okay
babe thanks babe did you do you hear
what they kept calling us babe
scars I wonder if that's who made all
those
murals and gutted all those
wolves e
gang there's an opening
[Music]
down the
[__]
[Music]
all right spooky gang I like this area
it's
cool how you doing Bry
Jesus have you ever seen anything like
this bloaters have acid
spores but that didn't sound like a
bloater there's a new type of
zombie interesting
hope so that'd be
fun Tinker Time Tinker
Time should I I don't know what to
upgrade
let's do
that double
scope
yeah that click of the light is so
satisfying me closing the door myself is
not so
much what's the plan I don't know I
grabbed the Rope across
there
okay how do we get to
it uh
what that's what I was supposed to do
right
yucky yucky
yucky I Plucky Plucky
Plucky Uncharted Vibes yeah
right come on Ellie pull pull
more oh I got it throw it like that
yeah you see what I
mean oh I got it I got it I got
it throw it like
this I got
it and then we Swang
gang swing gang damn
it
Uncharted to
gang
woo nailed it gang sorry I'll
stop what do we got what do we got what
what do we got what do we got what what
we got what do we got what do
got
got uh crafting what other the crafting
stuff craft more health kits no
need listen Clarity move faster
prone I have to learn this
first
yeah we'll do
that what do you guys think
smash like on this video if that was the
right
move ladder's
broken she sees that when she went up it
that's big brain Ellie I like
that whoa what just
happened they're a 360 for some
reason
what do I do
then say the guy who didn't look up shut
up shut your [__] mouth to me man
[__] you
[__] I hate you I hate PewDiePie
there's a window here I saw it before
you saw it Dina this way I saw it before
you guys saw it
cringe just get out of shambler so
that's the new zombie
out
I got you I got you [__] e e they blow
up smells like PewDiePie
g-u holy
[__] I've never seen one of those me
neither where do I
go where do I go
gang
found it gang I can't stop I'm sorry so
funny all right let's be careful
here infect I will not see your
flashlight thanks
game excuse me what just happened
I got blow over there so how do I deal
with
these
oh do they see me
though look out I think they saw
me I think this is really
bad
I think I'm dead
gang [__] run
[__] thank
you I'm definitely
dead
[Applause]
that went pretty
smooth I like
that zero deaths [__] Jesus
Christ [__] these [__] my bad did
they get
you no I'm clean draw a picture of a
giraffe Ellie
shamblers is that what they called them
yeah where the hell does sham come
from I don't [__] know but they're
disgusting that was intense it works to
just run
sometimes wasted a bunch but hey that's
the name of the
game let's have a look at
those
I do got a bloated ass at
least thank
you thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you
kindly they say there's a sneak
indicator to see if the zombie see us
what does that mean all right lost bite
no I'm not [__] listening to
you hell
no your PP in cognito cannot be
trusted it's in your name all right I
should have
known it's my mistake really
all right here we go let's see where
this takes
us
Paradise take your
time almost done
okay
epic oh ohow ow oh not that
epic it'd be funny if Lost Boy was a
developer just trying to [__] with me it
looks clear as far as I can see we
killed Joel we killed the horse and now
we [__] with this let's play
shamblers Cut the Ropes
yeah guess there's an indicat there yeah
Nature's an
[__]
One
ammo one lousy little
ammo preserve for shamblers okay so
small are good for
shamblers
gotcha we need uh
alcohol
well damn it's
dark need a
passcode [__] needs a
combination look around
gang coffee
gang hey Dewey forget the code again get
get me a soda and the code is
yours what does that
mean all right let's get a
soda oh nice one what is it 152 question
question 152 question question okay
enough hints if you can figure the rest
out I'm the wrong man I'm with the wrong
man enjoy
B their aniversary or some
shit2 what let's
see yes oh because they snap in so it
could have been only two different
combinations is that
why okay
nice
big
brain big
brain so
large
oh so big my
brain so big it's so large it might
explode at any time run
away run
away [__] I want more of this
can't I can't craft anything else
Lamers Lamers the
worsters give me that
paper well that's creepy hey doesn't
this look like a lady from the scar
graffiti
yeah oh God I'm so lost did we come from
here oh we're so close there must be a
way around I forgot to reload my brick
thanks guys forgot about
that jump down in subers
gang oh
no yeah but I still feel uncomfortable
about this the fact that I'm using it
[__]
shers [__] they're
everywhere what's the best
uh action
here how do I sneak up on this
[__]
who sees
me
I want to get this
[__]
nice
oh [__]
dude [__] I you picked the wrong
button I threw a [__] brick at
[Music]
her no no
oh that's a zombie
[__] oh God I dead I dead I deserve to
die I [__] up so bad he th Pro Gamer
move I threw it over her when there was
a button that said just
shoot uh okay so we're back here
then my bad fu
Fu all right let's do the same
thing it's all
good we're just chilling
homie
let's not press the wrong button again
there we go I pressed to just hit him
right instead of self killing and that
[__] me over so bad okay and then I
made 10 out of mistakes but it's all
good all right let's take this guy out
as
well all
right that's
better
and now we
mlly all right d that you dumb
[__] all right watch
this oh God uh watch
this dumb [__]
go back to hell oh
God uh why is she not
dead ew oh God it's all
burned ah it keeps
exploding it's it's all good I know what
I'm
doing a [__] you know what [__] this you
take this one dude you take me
for where is it hello sexy oh my
God thank
[Applause]
you all
right I'm not a
fan not a fan
they are kind of
sexy you can't argue with facts and
science
seriously
no give me
alcohol oh
nice yes
finally what I need one
more damn it damn it
whiskey down my throat come
on so this is the exit right let's make
sure I loot
[Music]
everything best song ever if you know it
you know it
where am I going
again where the [__] am I
going
there nope that's molded
shut
well at least I found a bottle no I'm
full [__] where do I go lost
gang there it is oh my
God outside
gang one
sec mind
game there is that a good idea until you
check the perimeter the perimeter of
danger no
trespassing okay I guess we go back I
don't feel good about this
anymore probably be live for another
hour what the hell happened here come
join Gamers some kind of train remember
gang thanks luck join the chat you can
be publicly shamed in front of thousands
of
people it's all
good
why am I lost every second of this
game
Jesus I wonder how long they kept these
running past outbreak day I
don't there's that
way and another note for
Jewels don't care
pause the live stream if you want to
read oh nice
finally
start getting closer to
light guess we have to work together to
get up here let me get you up there yeah
up
yeah I had a really late lunch I'm not
hungry supp I had a
snack what you
got let me
up Jesus you could have killed me [__]
come on
okay let's rally thanks babe we're
almost out you almost killed me babe
on
Jesus that scared
me am I supposed to press
buttons
nice Ellie your mask isn't she immune
here we can share mine no don't st stop
Ellie stop what no Ellie no stop I'm not
infected I'm immune I'm not coughing you
see [__] Dina uh you need to sort your
[__] out ladies can you run yeah yes oh
I don't like them running I don't go cuz
I never know where to run in this
[__]
game Run
Dina Ellie right here don't slow
[Applause]
down it's all
good this way hurry okay [__] go
right come
on I don't want to be first I hate this
stres me the [__]
out just
go squeeze
gang did I get
bit oh no ell's going to
turn Dina oh no dena's going to die no
oh okay she didn't get bit [__]
look how pretty this game is man look at
that this is so nice rest in that
theater that sounds so [__] you got
bit right she got bit
right almost
there dead girlfriend
gang I got
you
here oh God is she actually going to die
cuz I I was joking I don't want her to
die oh God Dina's dead isn't
she oh
no oh dead
gang all right we're good this bad come
on oh first see I call I'm a prophet I
call that every
time
dead Dina
gang
nice good use of chair gang
seriously look at
that yeah she ain't looking too hot is
she you want to tell me what's going on
with you oh
no oh what's going on with me
[Music]
H I just saw you breathe
spores yeah like she said she's been
immune yeah she told you you can't be
mad at that she told you twice okay
you're
immune come
on I Was Bitten a long time ago the [__]
are you talking about I Was Bitten and
nothing does this [__] not
listen the chemical
burn she's more for forgetful than I am
Maria and
Tommy and troll are the only ones who
know you're tearing me apart
Dena
no is she going to die though that's the
real question now you
know I
can't get you infected if that's what
you're worried
about I can't make you immune
either Joel made sure of
that come on show me do you get bit she
got bit something's wrong can you say
something yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes
yes I think
[Applause]
I'm
wor what do we who's the father
Ellie what are we supposed to do
now this [__] game
nothing I just need to rest for a second
are you [__] kidding me how long have
you
known I was late a few weeks ago a few
weeks we could
have we could have still turned back I
didn't
know I wasn't sure okay I didn't want to
be a burden well you're a burden now
aren't you damn that's a bit harsh
abortion
gang listen up I got a coke bottle and
some
cloth you got me I'm you feeling me make
sure this place is
secured you just
rest God damn it I thought she was
bitten someone said worse than bitten
when I said bitten what the hell did you
mean by that
who was
that
huh all right I got some cloths for the
baby I got some pills for the baby I got
more pills for the
baby oh God in the third one you're
going to take care of the
baby can't wait for Last of Us
three or you take care of the
child they [__] coping L walk
dead so the story that no one liked
let's copy that
one
pregnant [__] pregnant it's a
preganant but all right why would you
keep something like
that I can't can't hold it against her
really
[Music]
so that
what okay this not's old still better be
careful so
cozy very comfy
place
just is looking for [__] I don't know
what I'm
doing all right all right cut off the
edgy jokes
kids come on come on let's keep it
civil dude how comfy that is with the
rain I love when games do this where you
find oh wait never mind
I guess we're going to find the
electricity for that
right I was going to say when you find
the solution before you find the puzzle
which happens in a lot of
games but I might have gone a bit ahead
of
myself need to get the power going yeah
I guess we found the problem
before um
they can have a baby now that's so nice
this is that
great damn you get fried oh guess you
weren't much of an electrician
oh my God are you
Ellie are you an electrician got it
okay screws
here God damn it's
raining
so cool probably one of the best looking
games out
there just got to ignore everything
story-wise and it's really
nice
hey
wow all
right what a
puzzle that's
funny
put that away you
crazy so we got keys was there a broken
locked door
somewhere was the thing upstairs
or
downstairs
thanks downstairs downstairs or
downstairs it was downstairs
downstairs
whoa wow cool Joel you'd love watching a
movie in this
place oh too bad they killed him in the
game too bad they did
that too bad he dat as
hell this is a bit suspicious when they
go to the cut scene
spooky
no
way you're again is the real
father oh guys we get to play what song
do you guys think we're going to
play place your bets G ladies and
gentlemen
that's
[Music]
better what song do you guys want to
hear Hey Hey
Monica baby
[Music]
shark baby
sh baby
sh
[Music]
baby oh it's one song from
before if I ever lose
you I think I lose my
o food Wars is out on Netflix hell
[Music]
yeah oh sorry heartfelt
moment game over
[Music]
is this the oh okay
nice nice so this is the guitar lesson
bit that I was so confused
about oh I suck Joe just need to build
up your cuses that's
all all right come on this it yeah oh
[__] God couldn't they just continue
here please just continue from here oh
God we get to play oh my God I'm so
happy I'm going to start guessing yes
you want to spoil your surprise
now oh man is it a dinosaur it's it's
honestly just like walking dead it's
crazy the best bits of The Walking Dead
series after Lee dies is the
flashbacks where you get to play with
him is it a convertible you're not going
to get God damn is it a puppy
more walking less
talking mind your step I got
it oops
whoa
epic what is wrong with you you should
see your face right now what did I drown
you're not going to drown Brown got to
work on that confidence
kiddo yeah keep laughing old man see
what
happens this
way
worse Swim's getting better remember now
don't of the water with your whole arm
blah blah blah glad to know I'm getting
through oh it's time push time take a
look at this see it see just through
there look
yeah I see it push him push him push
gang push push looks
like you walked into that Joel come on
how's that
feel refreshing yeah it's not nice
getting pushed in is it
well actually we need to swim through
this part anyway got I got you back
you're angry and upset I am very angry
and upset now come on
epic troll
gang you going to need a dive under here
take a deep breath wish bu I got
this
cool wholesome
gang
damn looks slimy coming out of the
water is
it my sixth grade history teacher
wanting to apologize for being a massive
dick I beg your pardon my friend and I
would argue whenever we called the
fireflies
terrorists we got a lot of
detention you know you really need to
stop letting people R you up it's hard
when they're dicks
Point still
stands get another dive over here where
are you taking
me swimming with clothes on
gang this is very unexpected but
Pleasant is
it uh new pair of
sneakers how many do you
have not
enough you need some help there
Joel S death
Jo
y why am I not
gra nice
oh God the
hell whoa holy [__] Joel we're here oh
my God it is a
dinosaur that it is Joel
surprise holy
[__] it's a mother [__]
dinosaur
sore wait what I can actually climb it
what are you doing that's so cool be be
careful I'm climbing a dinosaur yeah I
can see that just don't die falling off
of
one look at me I'm on a [__]
dinosaur
whoa whoa whoa what are you doing don't
jump just climb
down uh broken back
gang I'm not jumping I'm going back I'm
not
jumping that was really
dangerous [__]
that did you see that yeah I saw there
oh oh wasn't it awesome it's awesome
that you didn't break
anything that was awesome I'll break
this glass no worries oh you can't
punch what's this uh oh we had that in
this house we saw that before it's a
dinosaur
book
okay all
right
I'm looking for loot forgetting it's a
flash sorry the dinosaurs are busy right
now what are you doing oh wait one of
the dinosaurs is here Joel it's for you
very
funny
that was pretty funny did you get it
it's cuz you're old oh I get it yeah
okay cringy jokes yeah I remember
someone pointed
out that they always crack bad jokes to
each other in the first
game
cool
what's she
doing brochos surus ate 600 lb of plants
each
day imagine the
poops did you go to museums a
lot yeah
yeah sah loved him I swear that girl
dragged me to every damn museum in
Texas that's
sweet I know I didn't click on
everything I'm I don't
know kind of want to get to the
point oh
a she loves space and dinosaurs that's
so sweet you don't like it um we can
head
back oh shut
up hey Joel can you name all the
planets my very educated mother just
served us nice pizzas
uh did you just have a is that an
acronym my Mercury very Venus
mother oh okay I get it that's pretty
cool never heard
that
[Music]
guess what the first animal
did I don't have to guess I was a monkey
no it was fruit flies yeah in 1947 fruit
flies it was to see radiation exposure
at high altitudes they lived through it
that g girl you are smart thanks did
they become super
[Laughter]
five damn I didn't realize this size
difference tell me another fun
[Music]
fact astronauts say the moon smells like
gunpowder that is a fun fact the moon
specifically oh well they would take the
moon samples back inside and smell them
later I
guess astronauts be like smell you later
Rock
I guess you can do that [__] yeah
where's a steering wheel Rovers don't
use steering wheels cowboy hat what does
that mean these
joysticks
huh hang on just the real
one considering they left the real ones
on the moon I would say
no dumb Joel
gang
a Last of Us four Ellie goes to
space you know how many times we've been
to the Moon uh
twice six times are you sure
yeah I'm sure I'm going to make it
seven I'm going to make it
seven yeah I don't know about the that
idea whoa there's a cowboy hat that I
can
find all right well you know you're
you're you're putting your penis on the
line but now whole aate you're going
into space you're going to need a helmet
oh right what was I
thinking Astro arcade says put the
cowboy hat on snip snip or
no how do it smell in there like space
and
dust after
you
watch your hand I can't live without a
cowboy hat to be
honest that's sick what the
heck
okay wow as you look at all these
buttons oh it's so so
badass
man could you imagine
just it's so
wholesome happy birthday
kiddo what is
this oh this is a thing that took a
mighty effort to find my Phil heart
crack take
it this is so
sad
close your
eyes it it'll be worth
it
okay oh
wow
seconds
second 15 seconds guidance is internal
11 this is
unexpected 2
1 lift off we have a lift off 32 minutes
the hour LIF off on Apollo
[Music]
I do
okay are you [__] kidding
me
you're welcome
kiddo what do you say we uh keep looking
around
huh yeah I
guess that was the nicest uh moment so
far in the
game
hey Welcome To
Earth
yeah she has that on her backpack
doesn't
she
yep
I thought I thought for sure the
transition of the countdown would be
back to reality I guess
not get some more
uh
here there's more Museum stuff over
there yeah I never checked out their
building let's go whoa
Jesus legitimately fell else much grief
get down
here hey jump
[__] you can't keep doing that rest in
peace
Walkman I want a good Splash we've got
more exploring to
do
Gano
nice not bad Splash not going to
lie Splash
gang hey who's me there yeah I don't
know I'll open the door for you come on
we can't chicken out
now
I think you did enough come on don't
push it
Ellie all
right
there there definitely going to be
zombies I
think got a bad feeling about this gang
news there's ship blocking the door well
see if you can find me another way in
I'll I'll walk around the outside bad
feeling about this gang gang you be safe
there dinosaurs
around I killed for
them uh
what it's dark in
here [__] oh I got a gun interesting
okay did not expect
this
come out
[__] go back to
Joel
crazy yeah it's
zombies where is
he
is that
dead excuse me sir do you happen to be
dead I believe
so kill thems gang
damn
Wolf Gang big
animals oh
what [__] those can kill you
man fat ass Pig
gang
poor G I'm in
here H was enough
fun it's just some animal enough fun for
one day come
on well let's get a move on I want to
get a fire going before it gets too dark
come
[Music]
on well well well ladies and gentlemen
been
streaming around four and a half
hours feeling a bit
tired
I think it's time
to uh save game
gang and see you tomorrow
gang what do you
reckon feels like a good time to end
it
uh that was fun I enjoyed the game more
even though it's so it's so crazy so
crazy to play this it's really fun I
enjoy live streaming it a
lot um so I appreciate you guys being
here I'll see you tomorrow with another
episode I'll schedule it so you know
what time it is and uh yeah see you
later gang
gang you know what I mean
yeah all right take care guys Broast
yeah